what is going on everybody welcome back
to our graphing financial data tutorial
where we left off we have this lovely
looking chart coming up here it's not
the most attractive visually but it's a
good looking chart for now and so now
what we want to do and now that we've
figured out how to plot the price data
we are we already have the volume data
so we might as well start plotting the
volume data that we have so how do we do
that
so what we're going to go ahead and do
here is add another axis right we've got
one sub pie here let's add another
subplot so to do that what we want to do
is we're going to come down I guess is
here and we'll say ax 2 equals PLT
dotsub fly and what we're going to do is
change up the numbers like I was saying
earlier the numbers are basically like a
square right so if you have like a one
by one right there's only the option for
one chart right but we want to have
multiple charts so what we're going to
want to do is we're going to say this is
a 2 by 1 so there's one chart well it's
like I guess it's like you know 2
vertical x 1 horizontal I guess is the
way to think about it this is going to
be number one so you want to edit
because like this originally says one by
one by you know one by one and it's
chart number one now it's two by one
this is still chart number one this
one's going to be a two by one oops
two by one but it's chart number two
name right so the next thing we want to
do is we're going to say for a x2 this
is actually you know a volume chart we
could have a line right you could just
draw like a line like we do with the
open high low close right it's like a
line graph but at most people do a bar
graph right for volume data so let's go
ahead and conform to that and we're
going to do a bar chart and so to do
that you just literally type in far
right
and in within the bar what are the
things that we want to do well we still
want to use date and then the other
thing is volume and again we want that
grid so we'll do a x2 grid and we're
going to say true you do want a grid now
what we want to do is we're going to
have two labels so generally what you
can do is like let us will leave date
for there but now that we have two Y
labels we kinda need to like specify
like which one is which so here we'll
come here and you'll say PLT dot Y label
and this Y label will again be stock
price but then down here we're going to
do a quixote dot y label and this will
be some remember this one so it'll
already have inputted it and then we're
going to just re input a Y label it's
kind of a hacky way to do it but that's
what we're gonna do and that's this is
the volume data now what we want to do
is we're happy with oh yeah we'll get to
that in a second um let's see
what we're going to want to do is I
guess well let me try I think I think we
can plot this now and I'll show you
where we stand at the moment so you can
see the necessary changes okay so when
we plot this now you see what we have
right we've got this volume data here
and it's actually blue if you can't tell
but like if we zoom in to the volume
chart you can see it's very you know
blue but as you can see there's a few
problems one problem is this isn't
showing date right so we obviously have
to convert this to date this stuff is
quite ugly and then also like let's say
we want to zoom into like this area here
on stock price volume didn't change like
right so we'd have to like perfectly
match it up ourselves right and like
kind of the point of programming is to
automate a lot of stuff and make life
easy so how
can we make life easy well turns out
it's you know fairly simple to do so
let's go ahead and do that so we're
going to close out of here and what we
first thing that we want to do is for
this we're going to say share axis or
share X share X and who do we want to
share X with with axis one this way
when we save that and run it again first
of all it gives us the converted dates
even though again like it's really hard
to see it right now if we stretch it out
you can see like the hold date let me
put it back on the window um but what
it's going to do it's special is if we
zoom into right here now this
automatically zooms in and like we're
like oh what happened on this day where
it was really high volume and we zoom in
on the high volume point right the stock
price stuff zooms in as well so it's all
you know identical same thing like let's
say you do this you're like oh I want to
scoot over a little bit you can pull it
and like now everything is like they
have x axis is shared between these two
bits of data so that's very very useful
now the next thing that we want to do is
for the label here instead of a x one
one thing we can do with a is one to
kind of cheat is do this and make it a
90 degree and then for label just copy
that paste it and for label and a x2 and
then change this to 45 now when we save
that or run it it's kind of cleaned up
this data it's still kind of showing but
we can kind well we'll continue going
through what we can do about that data
but for now it looks at least a little
better and we can actually see the state
information and we still obviously have
the same scroll ability where they're
shared and zoom ability and all this
good stuff so continuing I'll close out
of that
the next thing let's see if there's
anything else I want to do in this
specific video um you know I think that
I think we will cut off the video here
but the next thing up we really need to
do is if you've ever liked look
chart besides you know fix this stuff
we'll get to that if you ever look at a
chart and it's got like price and volume
like there's no reason first of all we
don't need these numbers at all on
volume very rarely do you actually have
like number stuff on that y-axis on a
volume chart so we can get rid of that
we can still leave you know the label of
volume that's a good idea
so we want to get rid of those but also
you'll notice a lot of times that the
actual volume chart is very small you
know like it's like maybe a third of the
size of this current volume chart and
then the stock chart is like much larger
because really volume is more for like a
reference and it's like something you
just quickly glanced at right so it's
not something you need to look really
have like a lot of detail so um so in
the next video what we're going to do is
make how to figure out how to make this
chart a little bit smaller and so yeah
so that's what we're getting into the
next video and then also get rid of some
of this data I just kind of cleaning up
this chart a little bit but as you can
see it's starting to evolve into a you
know a respectable financial graph so
stay tuned to the next video as always
thank you for watching thanks for your
support your subscriptions and until
next time